[Music]
and this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday January 18th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Tick Tock is in the midst of
negotiations with U.S Regulators to keep
the app operating here for the last two
years U.S officials have said they are
worried that tick tock's ownership by
beijing-based bite dance could give
China access to American data or allow
it to influence what U.S users see on
the app and as you may remember that's
led to threats that Tick Tock could be
banned in the U.S to prevent this Tick
Tock is trying a new tactic for
negotiations increased transparency here
with me to discuss what lawmakers and
Regulators are learning about the
company and how it could affect tiktok's
chances of staying in the U.S is our
reporter Georgia Wells hey Georgia
welcome back to the show thank you for
having me so Georgia you've been
speaking with people familiar with these
conversations between Tick Tock and
Regulators what new information is the
company sharing so we're learning a lot
more about what these conversations look
like and what Tick Tock has been doing
for the past two years and so this
involves a you know 1.5 billion dollar
effort so far to set up a new structure
that would be in charge of making sure
that the algorithms involved with the
app and that data it's safe and this is
their attempt to convince the U.S
lawmakers that Tick Tock could operate
in the U.S safely what exactly are they
they proposing to change so Tick Tock
has said that all of the systems it has
related to serving content to users and
determining which videos to take down
that those systems would be housed with
Oracle and the code that runs those
systems would be visible both to Oracle
and to third-party monitors and those
third-party monitors could check the
code to detect whether it had been
manipulated perhaps by the Chinese
government or other foreign actors and
that if they see anything that concerns
them there are stipulations within this
proposal where they would have a way to
escalate their concerns flag them to the
US government and you know ultimately
the US government could shut them down
if it felt that the concerns weren't
taken seriously why has it changed its
approach why is it sharing more now so
typically these conversations are
confidential it's between Tick Tock and
this entity called cypheus which is the
committee on foreign investment in the
U.S and this is an executive branch
panel that kind of looks so whether or
not apps can remain in the US safely and
also related to their ownership and Tick
Tock has been talking to cepheus for two
years
but there's not really a deal in sight
right now so people close to tick tock
are at this point where they want to
show what they've been working on in an
attempt hopefully to find allies in
Washington who could help encourage a
deal to happen we've seen some bands at
state and federal level can you tell us
a bit about those and are they playing a
role in how these conversations are
changing technically that process is
different than this process but yes like
that kind of has this overall ratcheting
up the urgency for tick tock right now
and you've got all of these local
politicians who are talking about Tick
Tock as a risk and so that increases the
urgency for tick tock to want to get a
deal done at the federal level to be
able to show that they're working on
addressing these issues right I mean
lawmakers state and federal and
Regulators have raised these concerns
about tick tocks data being shared with
China or maybe China influencing what
American users see but beyond that
theoretical threat is there any reason
why lawmakers are wary so weeks ago we
learned that Tick Tock conducted this
internal probe to find that employees
had misused their authority to access
the date of journalists on the platform
and this was in an effort to identify
leaks of company information
So that obviously is not doing Tick Tock
any favors when the company is trying to
convince lawmakers that it would never
abuse the data of its users
basically part of the challenge here is
that
tick tock's own Executives in the US
have Not always completely understood
how the algorithms in the app worked and
so back in 2020 there was a group of
tick tock Executives who noticed that
videos for certain creators suddenly
were seeing this big drop in the number
of views they were getting
and they had no idea what had happened
and they like asked around and nobody in
the U.S knows what's going on and then
they talked to colleagues in China and
they learned that there was a tweak that
tick tock's algorithm team in China
implemented changed certain aspects of
content that was shown to users and that
this inadvertently really reduced the
amount of political content that users
were shown and so this kind of showed an
example of take talk could face perhaps
an uphill battle and proving that U.S
Executives would always understand fully
what the app is doing and be in a
position to catch anything that can like
be tweaked with the app and know what's
going on when we asked Tick Tock about
the incident a spokeswoman said that
political content was very popular on
the app in 2020 and she said that the
hashtags Trump Biden Trump 2020 and
Biden 2020 garnered more than 2 trillion
cumulative views monthly at that time
all right I mean those are the sort of
big concerns and as you say they're
certainly not helping Tick Tock in these
negotiations what is Tick Tock saying
that about this kind of change of tactic
of sharing more information with
Regulators in these negotiations so Tick
Tock is at this point where there's not
a deal in sight and so now the company
basically wants to show more of its
homework the company wants to show that
it has been trying to address these
issues that it's working on it so that
in the very least when lawmakers are
talking about the concerns they'll be
armed with more of the facts around what
the company has been doing in an attempt
to address this it sort of feels like
we're hitting this inflection point in a
way lawmakers are paying more attention
to social media the government seems to
have leverage over Tick Tock because of
its ownership but how come other social
media platforms aren't having to offer
up changes to their platforms or reveal
their algorithms to regulators
so these conversations are about
National Security and so that means the
data of the users on the app and also
the content that can be shown to them
and so we are also like you mentioned at
a time when a lot of lawmakers in the US
have concern about the role of tech in
our lives and the role of algorithms and
perhaps like addiction to apps but this
isn't the venue for discussing that like
the venue that we're talking about right
now is just about National Security you
mentioned there's no deal in sight right
now but then what happens next and how
quickly can we expect a resolution to
this issue so that's the big question
potential outcomes could include the US
forcing tick tocks to divest so
basically sell off a portion of its
operations another potential outcome is
there's a bill winding its way through
Congress right now that seems like it
could ban Tick Tock but also we've seen
Tick Tock remain on phones and just have
this issue kind of percolating in the
background for a long time so I don't
know how much longer that could continue
but the million dollar question right
now is what's going to happen to tick
tock in the U.S because this is
something that would affect millions and
millions of users yeah I guess millions
of users will be watching to see if they
can keep that app on their phone Georgia
Wells thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you for having me and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]